[Music]
[Applause]
Tracy Morgan we taped the interview
right after the show because will was
still here and he worked with Will on
Saturday Night Live so we thought it
would be fun to talk to Tracy with Will
in the room and uh Tracy has a special
out on HBO Max and it's called taking it
too far stand-up comedy the very funny
Tracy Morgan and uh I opened up by
asking how are you trace
hey Trace how are you
I'm good I'm good you are my bro you
always been my bro where are you right
now
right now I'm in my home in New Jersey
okay and Alpine New York okay what's the
picture behind you
the picture behind me I paid 75 000 for
and it's Muhammad Ali's life and it's
called Rumble young man Rumble it's his
whole life his whole career
everything did you meet Ali
I met Ollie one time when I had a TV
show on NBC called the Tracy Morgan show
he would come see me watch the show be
filmed and I love them and he wrote a
stick he was a good artist he wrote a
stick a stick like autograph with it
with him in the ring and he beat
somebody and I lost it I forgot it I
lost that and I lost Richard Pryor's
autograph oh man I have both of them in
my wallet I have Richard pry's autograph
in my wallet I got it at the comedy
store in La I was with Martin Lawrence
and Richard Pryor was already in a
wheelchair but he gave me that autograph
and he says stay funny
and you have uh and by the way speaking
of which uh your good buddy Will Ferrell
is uh joining us here is not my brother
he's my brother he's not my buddy he's
my brother Tracy Will Ferrell's brother
Tracy how are you buddy
come on you know how I am without you
hey you're horrible Tracy you know what
it's so funny I've got that same picture
I only paid 25 grand for it
yeah
so I don't know well you look so wrong
and and you have the Richard Pryor
autograph I've got the Richard Pryor
autograph yeah yeah
oh my God wait Tracy I got a question
for you so what what when I when I was
flying out to Dublin on Air Lingus I was
looking through all the movies and the
TV shows right
and you have a show about sharks like
hosted by Tracy Morgan
yeah that was Shark Week yeah
with me and my daughter and I have a 20
000 gallon Shark Tank in my backyard
but I thought it was Brian fellow I was
like is that Brian fellows is now
hosting a Shark Week show no it's just
Tracy Morgan yeah yeah I got about 14 to
15 sharks in there oh my gosh oh wow I'm
a man eating in there but I had to get
rid of the lemon sharks because they
started eating my other sharks so I had
to get rid of them how much that set you
back
for my daughter
you know what Tracy that's about right
yeah if you asked my daughter what she
wants to be when she grows she'll tell
you a marine biologist
she wants to know What Lies Beneath okay
uh Phil all right well how much is your
Shark Tank
uh I we we only have we have a little
Pond okay yeah yeah it's not really a
tank okay do you have a lifeguard on
duty at the Shark Tank Tracy
absolutely not you know we feed the
sharks
run over feed the shark sure
we feed them Puerto Ricans no
you can't yeah you cannot
no I thought the Puerto Rican gotta go
and take him too
he don't come back out
okay
um Tracy Morgan community members out of
Puerto Ricans they don't want to give me
the joke
the uh the show is streaming now on HBO
Max Tracy Morgan taking it too far which
you uh just did there uh how do you
practice stand up
I don't practice stand up I was born
this way it's just in me
so you don't listen to me so you don't
read I practice a sense of humor you
cannot practice
you can teach anybody I can teach you
how to do comedy Dan okay but to be
funny is another thing
funny is another thing funny is a way of
life funny is your personality funny is
the gift God gave you that's funny
you could do stand up you could anybody
could do stand up anybody could tell
jokes but are you funny like LL Cool J
said from Hollis to Hollywood but are
you good I want to know are you good
okay but they so you could give me a
line and I could get a laugh but that
doesn't mean I'm funny
that don't mean you funny funny is the
Instinct it's your instincts
when did you know you were funny
in 1968 when my mother's water broke
you you knew you were funny when your
your mom's water broke huh I don't
understand my dad did comedy my dad did
comedy he was a funny man he did comedy
in Vietnam so I'm just mimicking my dad
out of all the characters you've played
all the roles you've had what's the one
that people always ask you about is
there one question you're not single
anything out I cannot single anything
out I love my career I love it I love
the gift that God has given me okay I
cannot single anything out okay but the
one now closest to me was the last OG
okay that was my life okay and that
wasn't all funny so if you look at the
show yeah it was a dramedy all funny uh
how often did you share the stage with
uh will
well will was our captain will is our
captain will was we fought a willing to
war and Will was in every show every
script every every scene will was there
where was our anchor he was our anchor
so he was in everything all the time and
I would just sit back and look at them
Tracy you you once told me uh that I was
like Kareem I touch I touch you all your
moves down on the low post
yeah okay I want me to Skyhawk yeah okay
and when you couldn't play I play center
even though I was six eleven at a point
guard I play center like magic when I
got a migraine and couldn't play
in game seven you filled in
next man up next man
let me tell you something our cast was
the closest thing to not ready for prime
time
I will cast the one we had I I mean I
love all the other casts but the one we
had not ready for prime time was neck
and neck we were right there right there
people who watched us because we had a
great Captain we had everybody was
playing hard when we got in when you
came off the bench you played hard
I mean we were like I was like a forward
and when the ball went up my coach said
everybody says crash and we crashed the
board baby you crashed the board
he crashed I went if the ball is on the
floor I want everybody on the floor even
guys on the bench I want you on the
floor
and that's how Lauren Michaels was with
us
and a great cat Tracy have you seen will
naked
uh absolutely yes I have
okay after the show we will all take the
showers so yeah
that's what we saw
he's uncircumcised
foreign
[Laughter]
well good luck with the special it's
streaming now on HBO Max uh any pretty
well yesterday I saw it was at 75 on
Rotten Tomatoes pretty good first is the
86 and 975 and Rotten Tomatoes so it's
pretty good well do you know that will
has taken part in the biggest box office
movie in Ireland's history we found this
out uh yesterday on the show uh he's in
Barbie and Barbie is now the highest
grossing movie here in Ireland but he
can't talk about it but I just wanted to
let you know that will has been doing
some big boy things
well I took my daughter and said my
daughter did a movie with Will
and my daughter did the Christmas movie
with Will we did she was in the same
will we did spirited together and and
Tracy was kind enough to be the voice of
a Christmas future yeah
well it's great to see you Tracy my
daughter was in the last scene and she
saw Bobby she said that's my friend I
said yes but you can understand her
older brother when I first got on
Saturday Night Live true little tray was
about six will walked around carrying
them on his shoulders
so my kids know well my kids know him
he's a good man so see I do like
children I love him yeah no you're like
Tracy's children you didn't like these
two little boys that wanted your
autograph over here he blew them off
Tracy they were like oh you're elf I I
it's it's not the will that we thought
we knew Trace I'm just saying he's a
different guy man ego I go different
game over here in Ireland Yeah Yeah a
different game in Ireland uh Trace good
luck with uh the show it's Tracy Morgan
taking it too far streaming now on HBO
Max
thank you very much Dan Patrick will I
love you and all of us you guys have a
happy life be good all right buddy take
care
you kind of you know you need a Hans
device when you get in your seat it's
not a seat belt you need a hunz device
with uh Tracy never ever quite sure and
you don't want to go out to that Shark
Tank no you do not imagine spending a
million dollars to turn your pool into a
shark tank
but
he did it yes yes more father of the
year because his daughter wants to be a
marine biologist
just make it a shirt yep